Hello, hello, BAU BAU...
It's time... What time was it?
FUWAMOCO Morning.
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru... yo ne?
BAU BAU!
All right!
BAU.
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm Mococo.
Together... we're... FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
I guess.
Yeah.
Thank you for joining us for our 43rd episode.
43rd.
43rd episode.
I'm sleepy!
No, my eyes aren't even properly open.
They're all swollen.
Can I just go back to bed?
No, I never went to bed, but I woke up on the wrong side of the pub.
Abyss, you don't lie, right?
You're awake, right?
You don't need us now.
You're good.
Moco-chan, I don't think that's going to be okay.
I wish, but... But for Ruffians that are joining us for the first time today, we're sleepy.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm not sleepy.
A bit grumpy too.
I'm not grumpy.
Yes, you might be wondering what this is.
So, yeah, FUWAMOCO Morning.
It's like a short format morning show that's held on Fridays and Wednesdays and Mondays.
It's hosted by us.
You don't need us here now, right?
Right?
Please let us know so we can go back to bed with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
That would be nice, huh?
Ruffians!
Let's all BAU BAU for now!
BAU BAU it!
To a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
And then let's all head right back to bed afterwards, yo!
BAU BAU!
I... I think that made me go ruffian sub-paro this time, or... Or... Was that it?
Or... That wasn't right, or... Was it?
Maybe I jumped a bit.
Did I forget to prepare this part?
Or...
Oh, no, no.
There's no Pero.
No, yeah.
I think it may be Pero.
Pero's still in trouble, right?
You know?
Last time he was tied up and everything on a train track.
Yeah.
There's somebody like that.
Maybe he didn't make it out safely.
Maybe he's still there.
Sure seems like no ruffians have seen him since, right?
That's very concerning, right, ruffians?
Did you fall asleep, Moco-chan?
No.
All we can do is hope, huh?
Maybe we'll see him after we get some rest.
See him in dreams.
We are dreams.
Yeah.
That's right, I... I... Moco-chan... Yesterday was our first YouTube short upload and... It was our first date on streaming live on YouTube.
It was our first YouTube short.
But we still had a lot planned, right?
We did a lot of things, right?
Yeah, we had a Twitter space over on Twitter.
Not on YouTube, a Twitter space on Twitter.
We did what again?
We tied up some of the FUWAMOCOs together with you, but... We also uploaded a new short video to our YouTube channel too!
Yeah, yeah.
Abort.
BAU BAU BAU, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's simple.
It's silly.
Yeah.
Mococo injection to your heart, right.
That sounds good right now.
Maybe I'll take some of that after I rest my eyes a little bit longer.
Yeah.
Let me just, you know, I'm just gonna go for a stretch in the bed and... You can't!
That's not fair, okay?
It needs to be equal.
I want to sleep too, so you have to wait for me, okay?
What?
But, yeah, that's what we did yesterday, so... Make sure you check out the new short, okay, Ruffians?
Thank you.
No, you already did!
We're the only ones watching you on here, okay?
Okay.
Well, the topic of the Twitter space, we did a Twitter space, not a YouTube Twitter space.
Um, thanks to Twitter now, our den is a little bit cleaner.
Tidier.
Got rid of a lot of fluff and fuzz, and there was a lot of fluff and fuzz.
Yeah, there was a lot of fluff and fuzz.
Good morning.
Yeah, and Moco-chan, you worked really hard to hold all the laundry nicely, right?
I did, but, but... I forgot I saw you in the dryer.
Yeah.
Convenient.
I forgot it, Ruffians.
And what happened to the laundry, Moco-chan?
It's still there.
I was too tired to do it.
I'll do it later, okay?
I promise.
Later, okay?
I already have wrinkles and it won't change.
You won't be able to tell, okay, ruffians?
It's fine.
Yeah, well... Whatever, I guess.
As long as we can get some more sleep soon.
Right?
It's good.
BAU BAU.
This is the next part.
Ruffians.
You know what?
I think there are no misunderstandings.
No misunderstandings.
Yeah.
Definitely no misunderstandings.
Okay.
I can't remember anything at least, okay?
Why, why?
Always choose and think and be careful with our every word, you know, before it leaves our mouths like a proper demon-god dog, you know.
Making sure we don't say anything that could be misunderstood.
No matter how energetic we are.
BAU BAU!
We're the only ones allowed to be sleepy, okay?
That's how it works, ruffians!
That's
Anime NYC!
What did you just say?
Anime NYC?
You know, it's an event that we're having the audience participate at.
What kind of event was it again?
What kind
It wasn't an anime convention.
Well, us and Advent, all of us, we're Advent.
We'll be making an appearance as guest star.
You know, we'll be doing some extra special appearances at the hololive booth and at the exhibitors hall too, right?
You know, but
It'll be extra fun.
But if you're not a ruffian located in New York, it might be rough, right?
Not actually.
No.
You're not actually okay.
As long as you have a VR account, you can do it, Ruffians.
Yeah, you don't need equipment, okay?
Wake up.
No misunderstanding, no matter how sleepy you are.
No VR equipment necessary.
You just need an account.
You have an account, right?
If you don't make an account, you can make an account.
Got it?
I don't really know sleeping in, okay, Ruffians?
You got it.
Moco-chan, you understand that too, right?
No sleeping because we're doing the performing part.
We should be awake.
If we're awake, we gotta perform.
Right?
Yeah.
Just like now.
Right.
But we'll be doing a Rock n' Rawr Party mini at 1PM PT on a Saturday.
And FUWAMOCO question and answer at 7.30am PT on a Sunday, okay?
7.30am PT.
Ruffians, I'll cry if you don't wake up for it.
And you wouldn't want to make us jealous of all that comfy REM sleep you're getting, right?
Sleep REM is a terrible, dangerous thing, you know?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
That was happy.
For a brief moment.
And then, as we got more and more done, suddenly more and more got added.
And, you know those were things that were missed?
They're ones that's ruined.
Like, very soon.
Like, tomorrow is ruined.
Yeah, not to mention FUWAMOCO.
We have our own projects like cover songs and other fun things we'd like to have come out eventually too.
You know, like we talked about, we're really happy to have homework.
We want more homework.
Homework is the stuff to, you know, to do to be able to make super cool things happen.
Super things happen.
I know it.
A little while ago, we talked about how maybe we'll have an actual day off to rest for the first time since debut.
But with all things away, we'll be lucky if we get one by the end of the year.
Yeah, but we are hoping sometime I might write.
Yeah.
We just looked up how to do the homework, ruffians.
We want to get to the cool stuff.
Cool stuff is cool.
Well, next we have the doggy... That's right.
Natto challenge.
Natto of the Day.
I know, but... Yeah, this is called natto.
Natto.
Really?
I did not do it!
Actually... There's no more left.
I ate the last pack this morning.
Were you not sleepy?
Yeah... You didn't realize.
I try not to.
Well, I... Ruffians, some almonds or something should be fine, right?
Moco-chan, you're bad with almonds, right?
I'm fine with almonds, yes.
Scary.
Almonds are not good.
Yeah, especially, you know, ones that were grown in the same place as the dried natto you had last week, right?
I can't eat almonds.
Almonds grown in the U.S.A.
I'm too tired to eat almonds.
Yeah, no almonds, right?
I can't do it, I can't eat the almonds!
I'm not gonna eat the almond.
Here it comes, Ruffian Moco-chan.
Moco-chan's going to challenge something she's bad at.
You feed me the almond.
I'm too tired.
My hands won't do it.
I'm too tired to do that, Moco-chan.
I need you.
I need your strength.
No, I'm not gonna feed you.
Feed me the almond!
I'm not gonna feed you.
I need to feed you the almond.
Okay, well, if I'm gonna feed you the almond... Just one.
Gotta be a handful, okay?
This one!
Here you go, Moco-chan.
I'm gonna... There we go.
Eat them all, okay?
Moco-chan.
Picture you two, okay?
I know that you're tired, but that's a mouthful of almonds.
Are you breathing?
Oh, the ruffians.
I ate them.
Did you actually?
Don't you have enough strength to eat a handful of almonds?
I can't chew them, I don't have the strength.
My mouth was too filled with almonds to chew the almonds.
I did kinda stuff them in there, huh?
You stuffed all the almonds into my mouth at once!
I did very lovingly though.
No, it was very rough!
I kinda just threw them in, huh?
Well... Ruffians!
That's amazing, she did it!
Wow, the almonds!
Awesome.
We're almost at the end of the show, right Moco-chan?
Doggie of the Day!
I was thinking about the sleeping part, but... Doggie of the Day!
Ruffians, here's the Doggie of the Day!
Aka goes BAU BAU!
Cutie!
Is this a photo of us in the morning, right?
Right.
Right, it really is.
It looks just like me.
It looks like me, but my arm goes up.
I know I can't be a very strong hair, but fluid is just funny.
Because right now, I could care less about fluid.
Is Akko gonna eat the almonds?
Somebody has to eat the almonds.
Well Aka, you could boil my food.
And I'll boil your coffee bed and then I can get some more rest.
Maybe... Moco-chan, stop yawning otherwise I'm gonna continue to yawn.
Maybe Aka could just finish up the show for us.
And then ruffians would be happy because then it would be a different host instead of us.
Because it was always FUWAMOCO who was the host but this time it would be Aka, right?
So it's good.
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning.
How does FUWAMOCO BAU BAU for FUWAMOCO-chan?
BAU BAU!
I'm not FUWAMOCO.
Thank you for the works.
Well, Akka doesn't really hide anything.
You know, food is important.
You know, you touch.
That's grumpy.
Easy story.
But you know, he also brings the energy.
The energy that FUWAMOCO doesn't have.
To protect the owner's family.
The energy we always have!
Mococo-chan.
Meow.
BAU BAU.
Say BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU.
Walk.
That's how you do it, Mococo-chan.
Today we're on the walk.
It says Doggie of the Day, Mococo-chan.
This is a walk, not a doggy.
Play.
How did you do this?
I feel really sleepy looking at this photo.
How did you make me feel sleepier?
Why this photo makes me want to jump into bed even faster than I already do!
Why is the point of a long walk outside when you know you could just go a few steps over to your bed full of warm and fluffy and fuzzy pillows?
Yeah.
Right.
That's a good question, Moco-chan.
Good job!
Stay warm.
Stay safe.
BAU BAU!
I think we got a question too, so we should probably answer that.
Hi ruffians.
There's a cute picture too.
I wish I had this kind of strength in my arm.
But the question reads, Hi FUWAMOCO!
Hello.
Good morning.
My school just had a sports festival today, so may I ask which of you is better at sports?
And which sports do you like the most, BAU BAU?
Sports.
I'm better at sports, that's for sure.
We play a lot of sports.
I'm better at sports.
But none of them we really like that much.
We do soccer and basketball and
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Ruffians, thank you so much for all your submissions today!
I'm glad I've been catching some more Zs, but instead you made these submissions for us.
And that's actually really amazing.
Thank you for making FUWAMOCO Morning, you know, something together with us.
Yeah, not sleepy.
Not sleepy.
Yeah, you know we're always looking forward to more of your doggies, and lots of questions, and Pero Sightings too, especially since you know, you know,
Next stream.
Next stream we have... Fashion dreamer.
Fashion designer.
Yeah.
Dreamer, dreamer.
Yeah, you know we... We're gonna get some more homework done and then take on even another job as, you know, us Demon Gaeta who become fashion designers.
Yeah, do you think ruffians will be able to work together properly as a team to be able to make the most fashionable and cutest girls ever?
Or maybe we'll just put some pajamas on them and then call it a day?
Moco-chan.
Pajamas.
Okay, well, let's take a look at our schedule, ruffians!
Go ahead, you can take a look.
I'm a bit tired to explain.
I almost done the show here today, so bedtime soon.
Duh.
It's still homework, but...
Ruffians will be starting Metal Gear Solid for the first time on Tuesday though!
First time ever!
That kinda sounds a bit more exciting than even getting 8 hours of sleep, right?
It does!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Thank you!
Thank you for waking up!
Joining us today for the morning, the FUWAMOCO Morning.
I wanna go back to bed.
We woke up, we all woke up.
I can't go back to bed.
No.
But ruffians, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our extra special ruffians today.
Yubi.
BAU BAU!
Neiju.
SQ.
BAU BAU!
Kedurum.
YKT.
BAU BAU!
Hannawa.
Babushuu.
BAU BAU!
Over time.
And to every other ruffian out there, we hope you can hit the hay sometime today!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
This means I can go back to sleep now finally, right?
Right?
I can go back to sleep now?
BAU BAU!